the Mexican military hunts for Joaquin
Guzman otherwise known as El Chapo just
one of the dramatic videos shown to a
court during his trial in Brooklyn New
York in this instance they were too late
the drug kingpin escaped through a
tunnel hidden beneath the hydraulic
baths but now two years after he was
extradited to the United States
prosecutors have got their man el chapo
found guilty of drug trafficking and
money laundering attended daily by his
wife Emma El Chapo's trial has often
felt more like a script from a Hollywood
film it provided an extraordinary
glimpse into the brutal and lucrative
world of Mexico's Sinaloa cartel and how
El Chapo became its mastermind moving
thousands of kilos of illegal drugs into
the u.s. across its southern border the
court heard how El Chapo was a man who
liked to enjoy his vast wealth carrying
a diamond-encrusted handgun and using a
gold-plated
ak-47 even installing a private Zoo at
one of his properties but he was also
powerful and ruthless the court watching
a video of him interrogating a man tied
to a post and listening to stories about
purpose-built execution chambers and
obscene violence
one witness even alleged that he bribed
Mexico's former president Nieto an
accusation mr. Nieto dismissed as false
the jury wasn't convinced by El Chapo's
lawyers who spent just 30 minutes
presenting their clients defense arguing
that he was simply a scapegoat and
acting on the orders of someone else
instead they found him guilty of all 10
counts and now he faces life in prison
where he will be held under the tightest
security El Chapo has escaped prison in
Mexico twice before once in a laundry
cart and wants through a tunnel on a
motorbike it's why he's been transported
to and from his trial in a convoy of
armored vehicles the Department of
Justice taking no chances with their big
prize one of the most infamous drug
traffickers in the world now behind bars
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News at federal
court in Brooklyn